the Federal Reserve on Wednesday raised
its Benchmark interest rates to its
highest level in 15 years indicating
that the fight against inflation is not
over yet despite some promising signs
lately keeping with expectations the
rate setting Federal Open Market
Committee voted to boost the overnight
borrowing rate half a percentage Point
taking it to a targeted range between
foreign a quarter to four and a half the
interest broke a string of four straight
quarters three-quarter hikes a
three-quarter Point hikes the most
aggressive policy moves ever since 1980
along with increased came an indication
that officials expect to keep rates
higher through next year and no
reductions until 2024 that's not good
news for those involved in real estate
and Loans the expected terminal rate or
point where officials expect to end the
rate hikes was put at 5.1 Tom thoughts
on this rate hike and any other data you
have on what's going on the market well
we can start right now with their rate
and so what everybody's hearing about
inflation oh wow you know 7.1 instead of
7.3 that doesn't mean prices are falling
they're just not Rising as quickly as
they were a minute ago so there's still
pressure on the American Consumer but
yesterday let's talk about the stock
market first so the consumer you see CPI
Consumer Price Index there are some
positive news on that and it created a
market rally and by the way there were
programmatic trades that were going on
did you see this yeah that minutes
before the CPI data came out somebody
knew and they were putting out
programmatic trades the market had a
rally based on some positive news on
consumer pricing but then
Powell goes to the microphone and says
well it's a half point now and there's
going to be another half point in at
least in uh February and we're going to
keep doing this until we can get
inflation down to two percent and then
that was a downer right so the cop
showed up at the keg party and now the
the market came down so that's what was
the market was reacting to but what it
was interesting
um that I saw about the whole thing on
inflation was right now gas is really
the thing that was driving inflation
calculation and a lot of people were
critical of Biden opened the Strategic
petroleum Reserve so what he did he put
more Supply out cheap Supply and so the
price of gas is going down now it's a
negative thing that he's using the
Strategic Reserve to do that but it's a
positive thing right now for people that
are commuting to work or paying less for
gas so it's a positive thing but there's
nothing else on there that was really
going down as a matter of fact services
including public transportation are now
up 25 percent you year to date which was
pretty heavy so that's what was the
market reaction yesterday but underneath
it pat inflation is still tough on
Americans by the way this the story Fox
News says five reasons why U.S could
lead into heading to recession in March
that's a bank of according to Bank of
America number one the yield curve is
the most inverted since October of 81.
okay they're talking about the 10-year
U.S treasury yield currently about 80
basis points below the yield of the
two-year U.S treasury so they're
concerned about that number two oil is
down 40 in six months despite various
bullish Supply factors including China
reopening this economy the Russian oil
price cap and empty U.S strategic
petroleum reserve and OPEC remaining
Supply constrained number three Bank
stocks are down 10 in just four days
that's concerning ISM manufacturer new
orders are down three straight months
during the current period of high
Innovations uh all together this serves
as a potential signal that business are
in anticipating or already expect
experiencing a Slowdown income customer
orders and the last but not least the
U.S home sales index is down 37 percent
year over year while home prices in
Sweden New Zealand Canada and Sydney
Australia are down 13 11 10 5
respectively overall the housing market
both in the U.S and abroad is slowing
down and that can be that can have a
negative wealth effect and hurt consumer
spending Adam well I have a question for
you Pat to kind of circle back to what
we just talked about with um the raising
of the interest rates
I think when it comes to politics I
think we're all very focused on who the
president is who's the vice president
who's like in the Senate who like but is
there anybody
more influential than the chairman of
the FED like is Jerome Powell the most
influential person in America today
right like if you go down the list
whether it's Jerome Powell go down the
list and who was before that Janet
Yellen then you had Bernanke then you
had Greenspan you had volcker like these
are not household names to most people I
guarantee you if you go around to most
Americans and be like who's this picture
of drone palette like oh I don't know
that dude picture of Janet Yellen like
like my grand looks like my grandma like
Nana these are not household names but
these are the actual people who are
running the country like we thought we
Trump it's Biden it's Obama it's this
person it's McConnell it's like
we get it these are the but behind the
scenes these are the people that affect
your actual money your savings rates
you're dead how much you're paying on
interest rates credit cards college
loans all that kind of stuff so
um you know you know it's crazy you're
saying this this is why for me uh uh I
went and I was talking about I tweeted
this idea today the last time I listened
to the radio was 2002. I haven't
listened to the radio since 2002 you
know this because my music stops in
2002. I know nothing after all you know
up until about like Ja Rule and Nelly
nothing falls off yeah when I tell you a
little this weekend we were playing
Spades uh at uh what he called one of
the events parties time I don't know
where we were at we're at Madison palace
uh place in Fort Lauderdale and I'm
playing Spades against swazo from New
Orleans whooped his ass when he was
teamed up here
okay from Memphis but until Jamie
Musgrove showed up was like she really
had she knew how to do she never made a
mistake but anyways two Armenians
whooped on a bunch of guys from New
Orleans Chicago Memphis it was awesome
but they were playing hip-hop you know
they're playing all this stuff and you
know I'm talking to the guys so tell me
who the top five best rappers right now
and this guy says well little baby
number one and I'm like and he plays a
little baby I'm like dude I'm nuts so
I'm not I'm not you don't know
baby there's a little baby end up baby
oh two I stopped listening to the radio
but then what happened was I realized
the I'm not gonna follow anything with
politics I'm not gonna follow anything
with the economy I'm just going to mind
my own business read my books that
worked out because my mindset got tired
but then as you get bigger and bigger
with your business it is very very
important to follow what's going on in
the news now here's a problem a lot of
people will say well dude I don't know
who do I follow I don't trust CNN I
don't trust Fox I'll let you know all
these people that say they don't trust
this I will tell you if there isn't Tom
you know I think you would vouch for
this as well if there is someone you
ought to subscribe this is not a
sponsorship we're not making money off
of this they don't send us nothing go
subscribe to Wall Street Journal and
read it every day okay I think the Wall
Street Journal if there's anything they
do they're the most fairest ones that
will call out [ __ ] on the left and the
right in the middle I think they're
straight up uh so my suggestion is do
follow a publication that you do trust
and I would say uh I put Wall Street
Journal in the first one I completely
agree with you and to go back to Adam's
point the president sets policy in a
general sense and he is very very
instrumental in a lot of the programs
that come out but you're correct about
the Fed the operating independent of the
president he can't really control them
but there's really two people that
control the economy one is the chairman
of the fed and the other is the U.S
Secretary treasury because that's where
all the tax planning comes so the
president very much controls tax and
treasury goes to Treasury and he says
listen this we're going to do on taxes
we're going to do we're going to cut
taxes we're going to raise taxes we're
going to do tariffs and so the Secretary
of Treasury on the left and then Jerome
Powell on the right and the president in
the middle those are the three that will
impact the economy but you're right the
FED very much has a mind of its own
whereas on the other side the president
has control of tax through the secretary
with that being said do I I might need
to recant my statement of Jerome Powell
being the most influential powerful
person in America maybe it is Janet
Yellen because she's had both positions
in the last few years she was the
chairman of the FED for years and now
she is the uh Secretary of the Treasury
so is Janet Yellen the most powerful
person in America not on the cover Vogue
anytime soon but she's going to be on
the cover of Time Magazine and other
things because she swings a lot of she's
got a lot of weight you're saying she's
not hot enough is that why she's not
gonna be on the cover of votes damn dude
I don't know Tom how would you just I
know a lot of friends from the Army who
are into that
dude she looks like she's gonna be the
new Harry Potter movie look at that take
a look at that is that buddy hakka yeah
Tom nobody knows who Buddy Hackett is we
appreciate the dad joke but here's the
question yeah I actually want I want to
go do that do you know who Buddy Hackett
no no what I do no stop it no bloody
hack it stop it stop you know that Tom's
telling jokes from 1960 and he's like
come on guys it's good right no no no
nobody knows buddy hack it but here take
off the glasses it was pretty similar
get him one without the glasses but
here's my question we're having this
debate over whether Janet Yellen or
Jerome Powell who's the most influential
to the average American like
they don't know who that like swear to
God be true Benny did you know who that
lady was I'm gonna be dead serious I
knew she had something to do with
Finance but I don't memorize like if I
showed you a picture of her would you
know who she is
no no I would notice that she's in
government but I didn't know I didn't
know like the Apollo guy I know he's a
weird guy with glasses right no that's
fouchy but yeah they're all weird but
yeah but this is my point is that we get
so obsessed with [ __ ] true up by
Biden he's an idiot trumps it like these
are the people that are actually
affecting your money yeah right yeah and
it'd probably be good to just know their
name so what all the craziness taking
place I believe future looks bright if
you believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks
bright here future looks bright here we
got them in white we got them in Black
we got them in red or black on black
sold out these are about to sell out if
you haven't ordered one yet we had a
person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people wore it in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hats especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody's saying future looks bright Tori
or future looks bright hat click over
here and to watch the entire podcast
click here take care everybody
[Music]